So, how did you do? The correct answer is 3 times 2x minus y times 3x minus 5.
Let's see how we got that answer. Whenever I see a four term polynomial, I know
I want to use factoring by grouping. But remember the first step in any
factoring problem is to look for a GCF. In this case, when I look at the four
terms, I know that it has a GCF of 3. So I'm going to factor out the GCF from
these four terms. So, when I factor out a 3, I'm left with 6x squared minus 3xy
minus 10x plus 5y. Now, I'm going to try to factor out what's left inside the
parentheses. When I factor by grouping, I want to find the GCF of the first 2
terms, which is 6x squared minus 3xy. The GCF of these first 2 terms is 3x. When
I factor a 3x out, I'm left with 2x. 3x times 2x is 6x squared minus y. 3x times
negative y gives me negative 3xy. The next thing I want to do is factor out the
GCF of the second 2 terms. Now, you have to be careful here. We know we want the
second binomial to be 2x minus y over here. But right now, we have negative 10x
plus y. This is one of the cases we need to factor out the negative. The GCF of
10x and 5y is going to be negative 5. The reason I factor out the negative is
because I want positive 2x. Negative 5 times 2x gives me negative 10x and
negative 5 times negative y gives me 5y. Because negative 5 times 2x is negative
10x. And negative 5 times negative y gives me positive 5y. My next step is to
factor out the GCF of the two terms inside the parentheses. Remember to carry
along the three, and I'm left with 2x minus y, times 3x minus 5. And these
second pair of parentheses is redundant. So I can just write 3 times 2x minus y
times 3x minus 5. Did you get that? Well done. Let's learn more about factoring.